Well I hear that you're actually a fan
of the "Pickle of the Month Club," is this true?
(Michael laughing)
(audience laughing)
I have my membership card and everything, yeah.
Okay, well, I would like to play a game with you.
Okay.
It's time for "In A Pickle!"
(audience cheering)
(pickle crunching)
Okay, we're gonna eat some sour pickles
while I ask you some questions; are you ready for it?
I hope so, yeah.
All right.
First pickle, we're going sour.
Okay.
Okay, ready?
All right.
(pickle crunching)
Oh.
(mumbling) Broadway song you can't stop listening to
and why.
(coughing) Broadway song?
Oh man, I haven't watched-
well, no, I watched "Oliver" the other day.
(high-pitched) Mm.
Hadn't seen that in a while.
So, something from that? I don't know.
I also like "Rent."
Of course.
"Hamilton's" always on rotation too.
I mean, sure, "Hamilton,"
but that's kind of cliche these days.
All right, take another bite.
Okay.
You're obsessed with mud larking? What is that?
Well, it's something I think you would really dig.
Really?
Yeah.
So mud larking, I just stumbled on it on like YouTube.
It's like, these people, they-
a lot of it happens in London and you know,
there's the Thames.
And so they like walk along the Thames River
and they find artifacts from medieval times,
from Roman times and you know, old coins, stuff like that;
that's mud larking.
All right, next pickle.
It's a hot and spicy one.
Okay.
Take a bite.
(pickle crunching)
(mumbling) Okay, what's the last lie told?
I love this pickle.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
Ooh, that is spicy though.
Yeah, no, actually it's not bad.
(Michael laughing)
It's actually really good.
Take another bite.
All right.
(Drew laughing)
(mumbling) If you could go anywhere in the world,
(clear voice) where would it be right now?
I'd love to go to Australia.
(Drew blowing breath out)
New Zealand, that whole area.
Yeah.
Tokyo would be cool.
I mean, there's a lot of places I haven't been to that...
Everywhere you named is absolute perfection.
Yeah.
And if anyone has the opportunity to go,
I highly recommend it.
Okay, finally, chocolate-covered pickle;
(Michael sighing)
this is a first for me.
Do I have to?
Well, you know, you never know.
(audience laughing)
All right, ready? 1, 2, 3.
You're stranded on an island
and you can only take one thing with you, what is it?
(pickle squishing)
Uuww.
(audience exclaiming)
Not this.
Ugh!
(Michael coughing)
Well.
Do people make, like, this...
is this something you guys bought?
(Drew coughing)
(audience laughing)
I'm so sorry.
Um, yeah.
Like, who was like,
"Oh, you know what would be good, chocolate and pickles?"
We did not make this, this we bought.
All right, well, I'm going back to the original.
I have to say, I didn't like it at first,
but it's kinda growing on me.
(audience laughing)
Can I bring a boat?
Well, that would be very resourceful, why not?
You get one thing.
Okay, mm-hmm.
Okay, will you please give us one teaser about what we get
to expect on this glorious, exciting season
of "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel?"
(audience clapping and cheering)
I will take your pickles, sir.
Thank you.
I mean...
It's funny. (laughing)
It's like, it's really funny,
I think it's the funniest season so far.
Really?
I think that's the only thing I'm allowed to say.
I got an email and it like, it had bullet points of like,
and it was just basically like, "You can't say anything."
So, I will say that I really firmly believe
that this is the funniest season so far.
Well, I know everyone's gonna be very excited for it.
And Michael, I just, I love you endlessly.
I love you in everything that you do;
you are the best actor, you are such a good person.
(audience clapping)
I try
You succeed.
Thank you.
You're such a good egg, Zegen.
(Michael laughing)
I love you, Michael Zegen!
For more, head to bananamores on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
where (raspy voice) Mitzi Bananamore visited him
on the set of "Maisel" to the button club where Joel-
(Drew clearing throat)
(normal voice) Joel is actually the proprietor.
(raspy voice) The proprietor;
you'll understand it when you see it.
(normal voice) And the new season
of "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel" premieres on February 18th.
(bright music)